I'm a rabid libertarian Gravatt
libertarian you know you make me do
something if I'm already doing it I'll
stop doing it even if I thought it was a
good idea that something I wanted to do
no I'm not gonna be told what to do
[Music]
[Music]
Santa Cruz is where I we broke free of
the of trying to accommodate the
prevailing norm both as a physiological
model and his business model and struck
out and opened our own Jim Miss fitness
for us is work capacity measured across
broad time and modal domains and I think
anything that you can measure you can
race when people go to the Gold's Gym or
or $24.00 they don't come out the door
every hour first place third place here
comes fit here comes eighth but they do
out of our workouts each time you come
in you come out ranked at least for that
last exposure and that brought a very
different kind of person around I was
living in Santa Cruz and I was a deputy
sheriff and working out really hard
every day and then I heard this rumor
starts to circulate around town and the
rumor was haze there's this crazy gym
crazy workouts in this crazy coach and
that was very compelling to me so I
found the number and called and Greg
Glassman the founder of CrossFit answers
the phone and kind of tentatively I said
hey can I come work out with you he said
yeah I come tomorrow morning 6:00 a.m.
and be ready and next morning I show up
one workout with Coach Glassman and I
knew that he had the Holy Grail into
fitness and I never looked back
I'm a CrossFit coach and I'm a CrossFit
athlete and I coach out of Greg's gym
here cross on Thompson I also coach out
across fit West Santa Cruz which is a
few miles down the road the movements
are our universal motor recruitment
patterns they predate history all of
them and yet there and they're
ubiquitous and in these things they are
they are everywhere except in gyms you
don't you're on a construction site
people lift things and squat and do all
those kinds of all day long but in the
gyms they do things like this the elite
athletes that we have at the
but also the athletes behind you in the
gym they are after what we refer to as a
ready state of physical fitness so these
elite athletes at the games achieved
such a high level of physical fitness in
so many Fitness domains that they're
ready they're at this ready state and
from that state with a little bit of
specific training in any other skill or
sport they dominate because their body
and mind are so so well trained they can
just do anything this community a fact
of your participation these workouts
you've kind of you've kind of veered
from the from what is the holy grail of
the fitness industry whereas I'm gonna
make you fit in just a few minutes and
without much sacrifice or discomfort you
know the ThighMaster thing or is gonna
sit here we're doing commercials and
have beautiful shapely legs
[Music]
markets are unknowable but excellence is
obvious to everyone and markets to the
extent that they are free and unfettered
will move capital in the direction of
the of the excellence
so today where do we stand from the
launch of that first affiliate seven
years ago we now have six thousand and
Counting with a 95 percent survival rate
the implementation the the value
socially and psychologically of enduring
and suffering and communal sacrifice and
sharing and we're building I don't know
if it's a Stockholm like Syndrome or not
but it was a captain from the first
Special Forces Group Michael Perry that
sent me a just a wonderful email where
he said that he had learned through his
CrossFit training just what the
constituent pieces were to the
camaraderie that was so essential to the
Green Berets and he said it was agony
combined with laughter the community and
the family atmosphere was evident from
the moment that Greg extended his hand
had said welcome to the gym kid I felt
not just part of a workout experience I
felt part of the community and a family
the USDA diet is a grain based diet and
our view is that the grains are best
consumed by livestock and that what what
homosapiens needs is a diet of mean
vegetables nuts and seeds some fruit
little starch no sugar
[Music]
it does happen with some regularity that
eventually you will push hard enough did
she make you so sick actually guys from
a US Department of Justice that had
first approached us and made contact
initially with that story that they had
experimented with the workouts and and
then delayed the experimentation several
times due to a mysterious flu that
seemed to wipe everyone out at the end
of the workouts you know we're
rough-edged and authentic and yeah you
might puke and we have a clown that that
pukes and we're putting them on the side
of our airplane because it's it makes us
laugh I've met pukey multiple times
multiple times but then again doing this
for competition so you kind of have to
have to go there so you know we asked
all the time is this a cult and we just
get pissed off and say no it's not a
cult well we heard it so many times it
was asked sincerely enough that is early
became important to ask the question of
ourselves what if what if we are a cult
I'm running and I don't even know it I
mean what the worst kind of cult right
no this is a this is an active loving
sweating breeding community yeah the
caveman thing it's a I'll tell you what
it's a I don't think it's an insult to
any any any crossfitter yeah cult of the
caveman what are you gonna do the whole
CrossFit you know political view it's
definitely rogue it's definitely
libertarian it definitely goes against
the norm against the man like screw the
Machine all that sort of stuff I'm a
rabid libertarian I found Milton
Friedman young as a high school student
I read fatal conceit in the Road to
Serfdom over and over and over again in
fact I they've almost been in serial
reading for 25 or 30 years and
profundities there are just just
spectacular these are works they that I
don't see refutations to so much as
reactions to this year we had a hundred
and fifty thousand er 150 thousand
participants in the open faith the games
are a promotional vehicle for the
affiliates because the open competition
with 150,000 athletes significantly less
than 1% of those will those workouts
will happen outside of affiliates boxes
outside of affiliates gyms in the early
days and by early day at refering two
thousand one two and three it was a big
deal if in the gym you did 20 pull-ups
now we've got people doing 100 pull-ups
I think our crowning fittest man and
woman in the world is as tight as as a
winner of a Super Bowl is in claiming
that they're their dominance in football
and that there's not much belief at this
point I think that there's someone out
there fitter hiding but boy we'd love to
find them you know people so often are
looking for the easy way and I think
that CrossFit is potentially not
universally attractive the same way that
playing the violin or learning physics
is not going to be supremely attractive
to people but what if we what a
wonderful world it is to to share with
people that are of the mindset that
anything that's worth achieving will
come with a substantial sacrifice and
commitment with blood sweat tears and
other bodily fluids it's always
fascinated me to think that the lessons
that we're learning in the gym such as
discipline accountability honesty
perseverance
those are great for the gym but more
importantly they radiate out into every
other endeavour the athletes do and so
yes it's a phenomenal physical fitness
program but also this is mental training
this is training for life and so
CrossFit literally makes better people